okay looks great okay sounds good
okay great so
good afternoon everybody thanks for
showing up to today's presentation you
know it's uh it's always a pleasure i
love doing these
presentations with investors excellent
because i get to hear other people's
approach to the market you know there's
so many different ways that a trader can
approach the market you know and it's
unlike any other
um business out there right you know
there's
a lot of i hate to say a lot of money on
the table out there but there there
really is you know it's a great
market
to trade right now it's a great
environment
and i'm going to talk about how i
approach the market using order flow to
develop a skill and become a consistent
trader which is really what you know
people always talk about you know
there's no holy grail in trading
actually the holy grail is becoming
consistent right you have to be
have an approach to the market that even
you know if you have a few losing trades
as long as you stick to the plan stick
to what works
the money will come back right
everything will continue to work as per
normal so what you're going to learn
today is why you should focus on trading
order flow what really matters in the
order flow
and how to use order flow to become a
better trader right that's all what we
want to do right we want to become the
best at um you know anything that we do
especially trading and i'm going to be
pretty quick and to the point and try to
keep it within the 45 minutes so just a
little bit about me you know i want
people to understand
my background and
why i do what i do
you know i started on the cme floor in
the 1990s
with dean witter reynolds i was a runner
and eventually you know i worked my way
up i left the trading floor i became a
globex trader i traded electronics when
electronics started up after that i
joined edf man the big
english trading firm after that commerce
bank the big german bank i traded buns
bobble schatz as one of a handful of
traders that had an actual ux license
in the united states
after that i joined cargill as a trading
desk manager they sent me out to
singapore to set up a trading desk when
the exchange was closing down the floor
and it was going to be electronic
exclusively
after four years there i liked singapore
i was offered a job with jp morgan in
singapore on their trading desk i was
vice president of futures trading and i
spent eight years there until i retired
from you know the sort of the corporate
world honestly i got tired of coming in
at 5 45 in the morning and staying until
five six o'clock at night you know it
just didn't give me any work-life
balance and i know that trading if
you're good at it and you know how to
trade it's something you could do on
your own terms right you basically could
be your own boss it's a very
entrepreneurial uh environment you know
being a trader
and about 2015 i started orderflows.com
it sort of came about as i started
writing a book on order flow
and
eventually i developed
a software that runs on ninjatrader a to
help traders understand what's happening
in the order flow and originally i
created the software to help my own
trading right because as i'm trading for
myself you know i realize i need to sort
of expand my vision rather than looking
at one or two markets i wanted to look
at more and i want to analyze more and a
computer obviously is going to help you
do that
so i sat down with the programmer and
said hey you know what this is what i
look at in the order flow can you put
this into software and
we started doing it and then other
traders were seeing my software and
saying hey mike that's great you know
can i get a copy and originally you know
it was just for myself but then you know
eventually the demand was so great we
started up order flows.com and the
reason i talk about that is because the
software generates the charts that
you're seeing in this presentation
now
like i said you know after leaving jp
morgan you know i i just wanted to spend
more time with my family but then you
know i started realizing
you know i have a lot of information
right and
the thing with information right that
you gain
you know over years of experience is
what good is it if you're not willing to
share it with you know other people
right you know i have this philosophy
you know each one teach one you know
pass that information along because you
know what what good is it if you're just
hoarding it that's why i started writing
this book and if you stick around to the
end i'm going to show you how you can
get it for free
and you know just a brief disclaimer i
do want you to understand trading
involves risk right only risk capital
should be used for trading
and don't trade your rent money
basically so
first thing i'll talk about is you know
why you should focus on trading order
flow and you know a lot of people
have this misconception of order flow
and you know hopefully i could put that
to rest tonight but really you know with
looking at order flow it really like
putting eye glasses on for the first
time when everything is blurry and all
of a sudden you can see you know the
trees you can see the words written in
the book and really that's what order
flow allows a lot of traders to do is
see what's really happening in the
market so like i was talking about
briefly at the beginning you know what
is consistency right consistency in
trading is not about being right 100 of
the time right no one is consistency is
about being able to come back from the
losing trades
when your experience a losing trade and
not being wiped out so you know what
that means is you know you have a way of
market understanding right and
you know you don't leverage yourself up
so that one loss is going to wipe you
out you know that yeah you know
no matter what
system or method or way of analyzing the
market it doesn't matter
if
you know you have some secret super
secret mis way of finding a buy level or
sell level that nobody else knows
because you know if nobody else is going
to be
buying it after you're buying it well
the market's not going to go up right
but if you're reading the order flow
right you're understanding oh this is
why the market is going up right now
because you see that same information
coming into the market time and time
again
now
understanding the market is what keeps
you safe right people get into all sorts
of trouble trading you know blowing up
accounts everything because they don't
understand what's happening in the
market right they think they do right
they're looking at a price chart and
they think well you know yes you it went
up price went up right so it must be
going up well they don't really
understand that you know maybe the
momentum is getting weaker or
you know maybe on this move up it's sort
of pausing but now it's starting to pick
up again and it's going to put in
another
new high so you know things like that
that's what order flow is going to help
you
become it's going to help you become in
sync with what's happening in the market
right because basically order flow is
the market right it's not based on some
mathematical formula it's based on
what's actually being traded in the
market what's trading on the bid what's
traded on the offer
right it's not based on trend lines or
any other lines you're going to draw on
your chart right because lots of times
you know you can just pick a high and a
low and draw you know any sort of line
honestly you could open up a chart and
just draw random lines and you can see
the markets react to them there's no
rhyme or reason to it sometimes you know
order flow is not based on fib numbers
or wave counts nothing like this based
on what is being traded by the people
trading the market all right what their
perceptions of supply and demand is it's
not based on you know outside
um
you know just i'll say outside factors
but you know out things that have
unrelated to the market right so we're
all familiar with the normal candlestick
or bar chart okay you know and you know
honestly you know when i first started
trading back in the early 90s you know
this is when candlesticks were just
becoming
popular right and
you know everyone
wanted to be
a candlestick trader right and you know
there's these books steve neeson
gary wagner putting out books on
candlesticks right so that's what most
people gravitate towards but all they
really show you is just the open
the high the low and the close right and
you know where we closed in relation to
where we opened which is is good you
know i mean that's you know good
information i mean you need that
information but you're really leaving
out a lot of other information like how
much traded on them
at a high or how much traded on a low or
you know where the most volume was in
the bar or you know is this is this a
pullback or are we going to start
selling off things like that and that's
what the order flow helps you to see
so
if you've ever stopped right to think
about
what's happened you know what's causing
a bar to form it's going to really
change your perception of the market but
all that information is derived
basically from the time and sales right
every transaction that happens is
recorded right this market trades in a
two-way auction right the trading that
happens between the aggressive buyers
and the passive sellers as well as the
trading between the aggressive sellers
and the passive buyers all right so
basically you have four types of market
participants you have aggressive buyers
aggressive sellers passive buyers
passive sellers
right and once you understand that then
you can understand how the market is
trading
right but the problem is time and sales
moves too fast to get anything
meaningful from it right if
you're trading in the evening session
you know nine ten o'clock at night
in the us times it's very slow yeah you
can look at time and sales if you're
looking at it during the day time forget
about it it's just moving too fast but
basically what happens is aggressive
sellers sell to passive buyers right
people that are working a bid someone
comes in
and sells it to them right that's an
aggressive seller and that will register
on the time and sales an aggressive
buyer buys from the passive sellers
right someone is working an offer up
there an aggressive buyer goes in and
buys it so that's how the two-way
auction works right it's not just
a bid and an offer someone has to be
aggressive someone has to cross the bid
offer line
now some traders like to look at a dome
right and they say well dome is really
order flow well it's orders
going into the market but not
necessarily trading so
again
passive buyers right are people that
sit on a bid right right in here these
are the passive buyers passive sellers
are the ones that sit on the offer
now
an aggressive seller is somebody that
moves their offer down and hits the bid
right an aggressive buyer is someone
that becomes you know says oh my god you
know i gotta get on i gotta get into
this trade
and they go ahead and they lift the
offer that's being aggressive you know
and
don't let those terms aggressive buy our
aggressive seller put you off or confuse
you you know
a lot of our everyday life we are
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
and sometimes even passive buyers and
passive sellers for example right in the
us it's a housing market
it's going crazy
the sellers are passive right they know
they could just lift list their house at
a price and it's probably going to be an
aggressive buyer coming in and buy it
especially if they price it low
someone's going to come in really fast
and buy it
and
you know
during the financial crisis you know in
2009 when all the houses were on the
market
buyers were passive you know people
could say you know a half a million
dollar house where the person that's
trying to sell it is underwater a buyer
could come in yeah a bid 400 000 okay
now the seller at 500 000
you know he's got to get out of it right
so he's going to become aggressive and
hit that bid at 400 000. so you know we
we all deal with passive and aggressive
buying
almost on a daily basis in our in our
lives sometimes we just don't we just
don't realize it right but we all face
it but the dome
also has its limitations it also moves
too fast
right now
you know there's a lot of people that
swear by dome trading you know i looked
at a dome my entire career ever since
they first having started having domes
on the globex system
and there is useful information on there
but now honestly it also moves very fast
right especially if you're on a market
like nasdaq or you know dao or dax or
anything like that you forget about it
you know the market's jumped up price
is not even on your screen anymore you
had to re-center it but again you know
it's all about the aggressive buyers and
the aggressive sellers what they are
doing in the market now
while you can see that again it's too
messy you know it's you know order flow
is great when the markets are quiet and
slow but when it's moving you need
something
a way to use that information
and benefit from it right what good is
having the information right in front of
you but not being able to access it
right
and
there's a chart out there it's called a
footprint chart this is the order flows
trader footprint chart that shows you
not just the candle the open high low
close but it's also showing you the
volume traded on the bid the volume
traded and offer at a particular price
it's also showing you
if there was an imbalance at a price so
if you have aggressive selling
in the two-way auction or if you have
aggressive buying in the two-way auction
and that will show up as
blue number in the volume it's
aggressive buying a red number will show
up as aggressive selling
right so there's just so much
information there's delta which is the
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers there's point of
control which is the point in the bar
with the most volume
and all these little
data points of order flow
really help you understand what's going
on in the market because you know again
remember what you're seeing happen you
know on your chart is what's actually
trading in the market right again it's
not mathematical formulas you know that
you don't understand if you you know a
lot of people use
indicators they don't even know how
they're formed right what goes into it
right adx i had a buddy of mine years
ago he was oh this is my dmi adx
crossover all right like it's some
secret system okay well
that's interesting well
what's a dmi
well i don't know it's just an indicator
i pulled up on on on the chart right he
doesn't know the calculations going into
it but when you understand order flow
you're understanding
why people are buying
or rather where people are buying and
their intensity you know that they're
buying or that they're selling but it's
actually what's actually traded in the
market right and that's important
information that's what you want to know
so
order flow right what matters in it
right because again you look at an order
flow chart and you see a lot of numbers
right people get scared of numbers
and
i'm here to tell you don't be scared
because you're not going to be analyzing
every single tick like if you're
analyzing a dome you're analyzing almost
every single trade that goes through
right and you know what i wasn't born in
the matrix i don't have a chip in my
head i can't do that
okay i need a simple way to analyze the
volume that's being traded at price and
that's what a footprint chart helps me
do right now most people will say well
you know i just follow price action
because price is is
is you know the best indicator well it
is
but it's limited right you got to
realize
price is just one piece of the trading
puzzle right it's like in music right
it's just one note right you can't make
nice sounds with just one note right you
got to put it together
right you put different notes together
to make good music right something
that's enjoyable and
you know analyzing the market is sort of
the same way you don't just rely on
price alone you could add in volume
trade on the bid volume trade on the
offer obviously delta imbalances you
know volume in a bar there's a lot of
information that you can take away and
focus on and i'm not saying you got to
focus on every single detail you know
stick to the basics the three main
points of order flow
is delta point of control and imbalance
all right you know i don't need to
analyze well it's only traded 31 on the
bid here against 150. well
really what i'm interested in is is this
two-way auction at this price
an imbalance or is it just normal trade
right the markets exist to facilitate
trade to transfer risk from one party to
another
right so a lot of the trading that
you're seeing is just trading
but when you see something interesting
something unique happen like an
imbalance that you know that should
prick up your ears and say hey
you know what
i should probably buy something here
right i see a lot of people coming in
buying i see a lot of imbalances it's
like you know last year during kovid
right before the lockdown
you know people started buying toilet
paper because everybody else was buying
toilet paper you know
is it buying imbalance in toilet paper
okay
and
all the information that matters really
can be derived from these three main
pieces of information delta appointed
control and imbalance now delta in case
you're wondering is the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar
it's important so you know who is
dominating
the current market right and
again it's
when i say it's the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
it's also you know in another way to put
it it's the difference between the
volume traded on the offer versus the
volume traded on the bid okay
and delta you know some people like to
have delta above and below the bar i
like to have it down here on the bottom
i like to keep it consistent
rather because bars you know go up and
down all the time right and i just find
it better keep it all consistent i keep
the max delta min delta
here as well because that's going to
tell me how strong the buying was in a
bar and how weak it was at one point in
a bar
but the delta
is just the headline number is the
difference of where the bar closed
and who was in control of that bar by
the time the bar closed now delta is
either going to be positive or negative
it can be zero right but that's just
more of a coincidence that it landed on
zero then anything
you know being oh yeah you know delta's
at zero it's perfectly matched you know
honestly this market trades so fast i
found that you know when it lands on
zero is just
you know especially if you're using a
time based chart like a minute-based
chart the bar just closed right it
doesn't mean anything
in that sense like you should get all
excited about it
but delta basically tells you who's in
control of the bar by the time the bar
closed right and that's important
information because you know most people
will say well yeah you know you got a
red candle you should have negative
delta
well i'm here to tell you sometimes you
have a bar like this green bar here with
negative delta
and that means something right it's
telling you that
there was probably some volume down here
to stop this move down right so imagine
if you have that information see the
market is selling off selling off
selling off then it hits this level down
here and you see a very big volume
traded on the bid and the market can't
get past it it's got a big negative
delta it's telling you people were
selling it trying to get it to go lower
but nope somebody just sat there and
absorbed all that selling
all right that's information you could
take
and trade off of that's absorption right
people think that oh you see the market
came off here it's going sideways that's
absorption but you can know right here
right now
you have the sign of absorption you got
big strong negative delta the market
can't push any lower it's telling you
someone's absorbing all that aggressive
selling right when you see strong
negative delta
and the market's not moving down that's
absorption
now the point of control the second
thing i'll talk about right point of
control is the price level in the bar
with the most volume
and
you don't need any mathematical formula
to determine it other than simple
arithmetic right you just add up the
volume that was traded on the bid and
the offer every bar has a point of
control
and you'll see it on each bar
it'll be highlighted right in the bar
okay
so again that's that's information that
you're going to use and that you can
trade off of
right
now imbalances i talked about that a bit
earlier
right they occur
when there are more aggressive buyers
and sellers or vice versa
more aggressive sellers than buyers in
the two-way auction now buying and
balance occurs when there's at least
four times as many traders buying the
offer than traders selling the bid
and a selling of balance occurs when
there is at least four times as many
traders selling the bid than traders
buying the offer
okay and
you know i this is a picture of the
tsunami in japan and it's really
sometimes like this in the market you
know even though this is a terrible
event that happened
you just get waves of imbalances coming
in aggressive buyers is coming in
lifting all the the offers or ways of
aggressive sellers as the market is
plummeting you know just coming in
hitting every single bid that's there
you know just looking for a bid and
that's really what it it feels like
sometimes now imbalances again you're
going to see in the bar right they are
the red numbers buying and balances are
the blue numbers
the black numbers are just your normal
trade right what's traded on the bid
what's traded on the offer
now
generally as the market rises
you see buying imbalances aggressive
buyers are lifting the best offer and
looking for the next best offer right
demand is present now generally as the
market falls you see selling imbalances
aggressive sellers are selling into the
best bid and looking for the nest bex
next best bid to sell into right the
sellers the supply is present in the
market right so
generally
you're going to see the market sell off
with aggressive selling
right but again like i said you have
aggressive selling down here but the
market's not selling off
that's the information that you got to
take as a trader seal what doesn't
happen sometimes is just as important
as what does happen right you got a big
selling imbalance here
the market can't go lower okay
as a trader right the best computer is
the one on your shoulders you got to
think well
how can i
what is happening right
how can i position myself well i know i
got a lot of aggressive selling here the
market can't go lower so
there's probably somebody there a big
buyer there absorbing all that activity
and then the market went back up so you
know from
price delta imbalances
point of control they all help a trader
find consistency right because
again you know if you're looking at
this bar here with a strong aggressive
selling
the bar's not going any lower
that's a simple trade to take right you
just you get long your stop is just
right below that right so it's not like
you know you're taking a fly well you
know what i've got this candle stick it
looks kind of bullish you know the
market traded down went back up um you
know i'll get long off that you know
then we're gonna place your stop you
know you don't know right just as
you know you get a lot of
candlesticks that look bullish or look
bearish
but then
five bars later it's failed already
right
but knowing where what's happening in
the order flow allows you to understand
where you can place your stop a lot
tighter where you know where you'd be
wrong basically right
it's just it just makes trading so much
easier and by being able to place your
stop
closer based on market activity based on
market structure that's really what you
know all these trading
gurus everybody says you know
limit your risk right cut your losses
short it's not about just having a tight
stop
right it's about understanding that when
the market
fails the reason it's failing
is
because of xyz right something's
happening in the order flow um you know
market sentiment has changed rather than
just putting in an arbitrary stop set on
a dollar amounts
okay so
you know that's where order flow is
going to help you as a trader so
remember right in order for a market to
move in the direction you expect it to
there needs to be follow-through order
flow in the direction
that you're expecting the market to move
right
like i said you know if you don't have
that follow-through order flow
the market's not going to move in your
direction right it's not going to
because you know you got your
super-duper x-ray vision indicator in
the market that says you know to buy
here for
whatever reason if nobody else is buying
along with you
the market's not going to go up
right or if you say oh you know
my
my tool here says to get short right i
drew a trendline i drew a line in you
know my chart and it says you know i got
to get short from here well if nobody
else is selling
instead everyone else is buying
you know you're going to get run over
right you're going to get stopped out
and you're gonna lose on the trade right
remember markets move
because of the actual buying and selling
that's taking place in the market right
now right it does it doesn't move
because of an indicator
right that's what people when they talk
about indicators lagging they think that
you know they got an indicator
that it's going to help them predict the
market but oftentimes it's
they're so far behind on the market
that
they're just left behind right you're
giving up extra potential for profit
now the last thing i'll talk about is
how to use order flow to become a better
trader right like i said you know
earlier you know people say well you
know if you're such a good trader you
know i traded for 25 years at a very
high level you know jp morgan cargill
commerce bank etc
and again i got a lot of information
that i've accumulated over the years and
the way i look at it is
you know you got to pass that
information on to other people
right and the markets are so big so
complex there's enough room at the table
for everybody it's not like if one
person becomes successful another person
becomes a failure no you know
there's enough food for everybody to eat
but sometimes you know people just don't
have the food and you know that's why i
say you know come here eat some off of
my plate right share that information
now if you're looking at a normal bar
chart this is yesterday in the e-minis
right you can see the market is just
basically going sideways going sizes
then it pops up here goes sideways some
more pops and goes up right now you know
granted the last couple days smps has
been pretty quiet obviously you got
jackson hole coming up that big meeting
so
it's to be expected so you can only
trade what the market gives you
sometimes the market's going to be quiet
sometimes it's going to be bonkers now
if you're looking at
an order flow chart
right you get a better idea of what's
happening in the market
okay now this is a bit of advanced
concept here but if you're looking at
what's happening here
if you know
this bar if you can look at this bar you
can see it's a very bullish bar based on
the order flow this is what we call
order flow sequencing where it's just it
lifts every every offer that gets lifted
is higher higher higher right so
basically what someone's coming in and
you know people are expecting this
market to go lower that's why they're
offering out more here more here and
more here but a buyer came in and
basically hoovered all that up
okay so someone was stacking the order
book
in anticipation of the market to go down
now
again if you're not familiar with order
flow it's hard to see
right but if you have a software right
my order flows trader will highlight
these areas to you like this boom so you
know that you got bullish order flow
all right
now here's another example right this is
e-mini's yesterday
again very
lifeless market basically just
very boring yesterday
back and forth back and forth but then
there you get a little bit of a move
finally you get a little bit of a dump
from the 94 and a half 95 area down to
the 92 92 and a half area
but for most traders you know trying to
figure this out is like you know if
you're looking at a bar chart you're
thinking ah we're just going sideways
maybe we sell off come back down to this
low rally back up
but if you're looking at the order flow
it's very clear
what was happening in here right
you got this little
bearish activity coming in right in here
right but again it takes time to
understand that that's why i created my
order flows software is because i want
to be highlighted to those points of
control that matter
right you can see you got a bearish
point of control right in here and boom
it's sold off
okay so the next one talk about this is
crude oil yesterday
now
you know crude oil you know on days that
equities are moving slow fortunately you
got other markets that you can trade
like crude oil crude oil
moves quickly sometimes and yesterday
was kind of a normal day in crude and
nice price rotations but again market
just looks like it's going sideways in
here right nothing really to get too
excited about right in the order flow
you're seeing points of control sort of
matched up delta not really too much
directional one way or the other
not necessarily a whole lot of
imbalances but again
there's just you know that one little
market nuance that tells you
this
point of control what's happening down
in here is is bullish right right before
you
um you know rally about 30 points
in the next five minutes right that's
the benefit of using order flow because
you know a question a lot of people ask
is
um you know mike i use a 15 minute chart
or you know 30 minute chart can i use
order flow well you can there's ways to
use it but
the best way to use order flow is right
now right
trade what's happening
right in front of you basically
take advantage of that information that
bullish information or the bearish
information and trade off of it rather
than waiting for this market to rally up
here say hey you know it looks like we
got a break out of this range and then
by that time you've already given up an
extra uh 10 ticks of potential profit
this is soybeans right very similar to
you know crude oil just showing you here
right basically a sideways market
and then it pops up
right a little sideways market then it
pops up
okay
what if you had software that can show
you these
this activity right you're seeing
sort of sideways market but it's getting
ready for a pop right that's why it
highlights this point of control green
it's telling you hey you know wake up
this market's potentially getting ready
to rally
and it rallies
again it's a nice move almost a 10 cent
move which is 500 move in soybeans and
it happens basically one two three four
five six seven seven minutes and then
you get a bearish signal here right once
we rallied up 10 cents it sort of went
sideways but now you're getting a
bearish signal here and the market sold
off again back down to the 20s
so again that's why having software
that can help you
analyze the market is just going to put
you so far ahead of a lot of traders
that are waiting for this breakout right
imagine you're trading this market
right and you have your oh you say 28 is
the high i'm gonna wait for a break out
okay you get long at 29. well you should
have been long from 27
28 rather than 29 or 30. right so it's
going to help you understand
where the activity is happening so that
you can take advantage of it as soon as
it happens right because that's what you
want to do right you want to take
advantage of
what's happening as quickly as
possible now the next thing i'll talk
about is imbalances
all right and
again you know you see a lot of bars
have both buying and selling imbalances
but then you're going to notice some
bars have a lot of buying imbalances
directional
or a lot of selling imbalances
directional in the opposite direction
and
again if you're
newer to order flow or even if you've
been using order flow for a while
you know most traders are familiar with
a stacked imbalance which is three or
more imbalances stack neatly on top of
each other and while it's pretty on a
chart
a lot of times you don't get those
imbalances stacked neatly on top of each
other sometimes they're spread out
one two three
right there's one and then two and three
up here now if you're looking for
stacked imbalance it doesn't happen
until way up here
or another one up here but by this time
the market's already moved from you know
28 and a half all the way up to 31 and a
half 32.
would you rather be alerted to hey you
know what i was already aggressive
buying coming in here that matters
getting long now
and then enjoying that stacked
imbalances when they come in here these
are the bars that you love as a trader
right the bars that in this case you
know open at 29 closed at you know
almost 35
you know those big bars in your
direction when your position that
happens so fast and then what happens
market goes up
we then go sideways it starts coming
down then you're starting to see
the selling imbalances coming in in this
bar you got one two three so i got my
software will highlight it the bar it'll
put a just a simple box around it right
it doesn't need to be anything fancy
traders like to over complicate things
keep it simple
right keep it simple you don't get a
stacked imbalance until over here but
you're already alerted to hey you know
what there's a lot of selling coming in
now you know around the 32 area
rather than 29 and a half
so it's coming in you know you're coming
in two three cents ahead of time all
right you're getting short ahead of time
and all that information is available to
you
it's not like you're trading on inside
information no this is what traded
but if you're not looking for that
information you can't profit from it
this is crude oil yesterday right nice
move up right from
basically you know the 65 area all the
way up to the 668.00 67.65 to 68.00 nice
35 cent move in about 10 minutes 15
minutes
but unless you picked up that there is
the aggressive buying was coming in
enforced in the form of multiple
imbalances
you're not going to notice it right here
this bar this bar this bar again if
you're trading for a breakout you know
maybe you're missing it maybe you're
getting in later you're giving up
ticks right and
again you know why should you that's why
i talk about you know money being on the
table is you know you want to take
advantage of everything that's out there
right all the tools all the information
that's out there because you know we're
we're in an arms race right now in terms
of data
right and
individual retail traders we can't
compete with the big hedge funds the
quant funds you know people are running
these super computers
to analyze data and all that and i'll be
honest all this information you're
seeing on a footprint chart is being
analyzed as well
by
other professional traders with bigger
budgets um bigger computing power than
all of us so if you're not looking at
this information
you're really going to be left in the
dust one day if you're a short-term
intraday trader
again this is 6e right the euro currency
futures on the cme
all right and again you know if you can
pick up that hey you know what there's
aggressive buying coming in here
right after this little bit of a
pullback you know as the market's
pulling back are you thinking
well is this just a pullback and we're
going to go back up or is this the
market falling over
but you can see here look at this each
bar over this five minute period has
very strong aggressive buying
multiple imbalances multiple imbalances
multiple imbalances right as this market
keeps going up and up and up
again now this is gold right you can see
it here right right before the market
sold off from this 97 area down into the
you know below 90
this was your clue right here right the
multiple imbalances
right mini dow yesterday right same
thing market rallied up above 50 points
your clue was here in this bar multiple
imbalances say okay say you missed this
bar you get in here right there's still
points to be had
all right so
there's
it happens in
all markets every day you know they're
consist of people trading the market
right and
their behavior
while
not
exactly 100 repeatable is very fractal
in nature right it does repeat itself
you know a lot of these charts i showed
you look very alike right this chart
looks a lot like this chart right this
is the crude oil
all right this is the euro currency you
know
this one's at 8 50 in the morning
right 8 50 9 o'clock in the morning in
the euro currency
whoops gold i'm sorry crude oil it
happened two hours later right 10 50 in
the morning and it looks very similar
right but you see it over and over and
over in the markets right and this gold
chart
it looks you know the same if you were
to flip over the euro currency in the
crude chart it looks very similar in
this case it's selling imbalances that
are coming in
so you know to be honest there's just so
much more i'd love to show you but
there's just not enough time today right
so hopefully you can see how powerful
order flow analysis really is right
again don't need to over complicate
trading just trade what you're seeing
right just trade what's happening right
in front of you
so if you found this helpful you're
going to really like the overflows
trader 3.0 software package which makes
order flow analysis so easy right
because
order flow provides the trader advanced
information that they need to get an
edge over other traders you know
everyone always says open up a book open
up whatever
video
you need an edge okay
well how do i get an edge well i'm just
showing you how you get an edge using
just imbalances or points of control
right and there's just there's a lot of
other ways you can use order flow to get
those edges
because order flow allows you to see and
understand what's happening in the
market that other traders don't see
so hopefully let me ask this question
right who wants to add
order flow analysis to their trading
right
hopefully everybody so you could do this
on your own
you could spend a year looking at a
screen trying to figure out order flow
but honestly what's going to happen is
you're going to waste a year losing more
money right and when i ask you next year
how's it going you're going to be like
sylvester stallone you know all beat up
and shot yeah it's going good you know
even though you just lost blew up a
couple training accounts etc
now or two you can get the education and
software from a trader who has
successfully traded order flow at the
highest level for decades right you're
going to skip the massive trading losses
skip the wasted time
so the order flows trader
3.0 runs on ninjatrader okay runs on the
ninjatrader 8 it's a volume footprint
chart with 17 pre-programmed order flow
indicators i talked about two today i
talked about the point of control one
which is the slingshot point of control
and i talked about the
imbalances
all right the multiple imbalances
i say you get my chart template but
honestly in this new version you don't
need a chart template because when you
install the software
the defaults are my defaults set up for
an e-mini one-minute chart and normally
the software sells for 8.99
on my website but you're not going to
pay that
today right
but i realize right having order flow is
one thing right you have to know how
to use it know what you're looking at so
let's give you the software and send you
on your way i provide a lot of education
on how to trade with order flow right
and each week i do a live group training
session for users right so if you can't
attend you could watch the recording um
as of this week i've got 133 recordings
so you can see it goes back how many
years right goes back to 2018 actually
now i don't expect you to watch every
one but
you know it's there as a resource for
you and each week again you could come
in
and watch it attend it right you got
questions want me to ask you know ask me
mike what about this market what chart
should i be using
um you know if i'm looking at
you know wheat or something what do you
recommend you know or what settings
should i be looking at because there's a
lot of different settings for different
markets that some perform better than
others
now some people
will sell you software and say oh yeah
you want my training it's going to cost
you extra no it's free right it should
be free right you buy the software you
make the investment in yourself in
software
they should give you training with it
right and that's what i do right so
again you know if you can't reach me for
whatever reason you know saying you know
you can always find me there i'm always
there tuesday nights at 7 00 p.m chicago
time
so that's the live training right and i
also got recorded training right my
order flows trading course which
i also sell for 297 you can get that for
free
right this is a 20 lesson course on
trading order flow and for those that
want to sort of step it up you also get
access to
the inner circle video series which i
did a few years ago there's 56 videos on
advanced order flow tricks tips and
analysis
you get access to that for free as well
so you start adding that up right the
software the training the video series
and the weekly group training
it's you know
sixteen hundred seventeen hundred close
to two thousand dollars
but again you're not going to pay that
today
and
you know because anna keeps having me
back i got even a special bonus for you
right my investors expo bonus which is
the order flows playbook you can get
that for free no i sell this for 297
right and i sell copies you know all the
time let me give you that for free
so
you know you're close to paying close to
two thousand dollars
right but again i don't want you to pay
that
now you know other people are saying you
know the training the software is great
because they can clearly see now what's
happening in the market right because at
the end of the day that's what you want
to do is you want to understand what's
happening in the market
so again it's up to you right
everyone's got dreams of financial
freedom and success but at the end of
the day it's up to you you've got to
make it happen all right you got to take
that step make that investment in
yourself so for just a one-time payment
of 749 you're going to get it
right you're going to get access to all
that information right just go to
orderflows.com
off 3.
and you know the link is there in the
chat i put it in there i think anna's
got it in there as well
and
go to it it takes you to a page
just looks just like this
what you're going to do is you're going
to scroll down right there's a little
thing here you just scroll down
it's going to take you to this button
click here to buy now now there's videos
and and other instruction on there if
you want to learn more about the
software
and when you click on that button that
says buy now it takes you to paypal
right paypal processes your payment not
me
i don't get your credit card i don't
want your credit card information you
know i'm just here to to trade basically
now
if you're interested in my book on order
flow it's a great
way to understand order flow for
beginners
even advanced you know traders will
get a kick out of it go to
orderflows.combook.html
and you got to enter your name and email
address you just don't go to this page
and it's right there you got to enter
your name and email address then you got
to hit submit all right then takes you
to the page where you can download the
book
so
act now right basically you got to do
something you know you got to take that
step forward right because you know
we've been on
you know cobit happened last year
everyone was on lockdown right some
people started to trade some people made
money some people a lot of people lost
money
but
really trading is a life skill that you
could have with you
for the rest of your life right whether
you're
40 50 60 70 as long as you know how to
trade
you're golden basically so go to
www.orderflows.com3.html
and i'll see you guys on the inside so
anna thanks for having me i'll throw it
back to you now
thank you so much michael
and i'm excited to invite
next presenter
for the first time on our show